new tonight replacing chronic pain with
peace
that's the goal of the nevada end of
life options act an assembly bill
introduced during this year's
legislative session
now it would allow those who are
terminally ill to die peacefully by
taking medication
and it's an option 73 percent of
nevadan's support
sasha loftus spoke with one woman who's
counting on it she joins us now live
with more on her message tonight sasha
denise the woman i spoke with tonight
has been through years of pain
and uncertainty she says she's simply
looking for a way to stop her suffering
once treatment is no longer an option
every day it's gotten harder and harder
hannah olivas has a close connection to
chronic pain i wake up and it's hard to
get up
i'm in pain my my i've fractured my ribs
twice
because it affects the bones she has
multiple myeloma
a terminal blood cancer that's taken
over her life
so when her time comes she wants to make
her own choice
i want my family to see me happy
i want them to see me die peacefully
she's one of many
advocating for nevada assembly bill 351
the end of life options act this is
really the definition of a nonpartisan
issue
the 2021 legislation would allow a
patient with
six months or less to live who's able to
make sound decisions to take medication
to peacefully die in their sleep
it's a safe option for patients who want
to have a more peaceful passing
a similar proposal was presented in 2019
and ran out of time
but sam dewitt of compassion choices
action network says
since then safeguards have been
strengthened until it happens to you you
have no idea what we feel
as for hannah she hopes her story will
illustrate the importance of
peace after so much agony this is not
suicide
and this is an option that all nevadans
should have
now on april 7 ab-351 will be presented
to the
nevada assembly health and human
services committee
if it passes through that it will go to
the assembly floor then go through the
same process through the nevada senate
and if it passes through that it will go
to governor siselek's desk to sign into
law
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now